pop
[Musique]
e
mais
il ya plusieurs sortes d'histoires comme
il ya plusieurs sortes de télévision
évidemment l'histoire qui étudie les en
mouvement des peuples et des
civilisations
il y as télévision qui utilisent des
très grands moyens des grands studios de
nombreuses distributions via aussi
l'histoire qu'ils racontent des
histoires et la télévision qui se borne
à un seul acteur c'est à dire lamy qui
raconte des histoires à ses amis eh bien
je choisirais ce second genre d'histoire
et c'est second genre de télévision
l'histoire que nous allons raconter ce
soir est une histoire relativement
récente puisque elle commence en 1956
très exactement mois d'avril 1956 je ne
sais pas si vous vous souvenez de ce qui
s'est passé en avril 1956 mais c'était
l'époque où le maréchal boulga nine et
monsieur nikita khrouchtchev faisait
sorte de tournée de la séduction
il n'y avait que trois ans que le
généralissime staline était mort et
khrouchtchev et boulga nine avait décidé
de faire comme on dit une ouverture une
ouverture à l'ouest alors il se
promenait tous les deux de capitale en
capitale il y avait le maréchal mogan
nsa et sa courte barbiche vous savez que
les barbes inspire confiance et il y
avait monsieur khrouchtchev qui
commençaient à lancer ses réflexions à
l'emporte-pièce qui laissait sidéré les
gens de l'ouest qui n'étaient pas
habitués à ça avec évidemment joseph
staline et la tournée de la séduction
avec conduit en ce mois d'avril 56
khrouchtchev et boulga nine en
angleterre il était arrivé sur un bateau
sur un croiseur lord john keats qui
avait jeté l'ancré dans la rade de port
sens et c'est là que commence notre
histoire notre histoire qui va nous
conduire à nous occuper d'un homme dont
le nom était lionel crap lionel crabe
probablement le plus étonnant le plus
extraordinaire des hommes grenouilles
qui ait jamais existé
or le 19 avril 1956
lionel crabe est à portsmouth il est
arrivé deux jours plus tôt où il est
descendu avec un ami qui s'appelle smith
smith étalons commode
il descendit les descendu aux salles les
portes hôtels 1 m 58 brin l'air assez
chétif un costume de chevillotte voilà
la lure de l'homme qui ce 19 avril à 7
heures du matin quitte le salit porte
hôtel avec son ami smith ils s'en vont
et à partir de cette heure là nul ne
reverra vivant ou mort lionel crabe en
angleterre crabe avant 1939 bien
quelqu'un qui n'avait jamais fait parler
de lui naturellement il le veut
s'engager dans la marine en 39 on le
refuse
on le trouve trop petit il n'a de vision
que 20% à des deux yeux en plus il a
pour mon voile et il faut qu ils
insistent beaucoup enfin on langage dans
les bureaux de la marine on l'envoie à
gibraltar où il est perdu dans un océan
de papiers administratifs
un détail en 1939
lionel crabe ne sait pas nager et
probablement ne serait-il jamais sorti
de l'anonymat
si au mois de septembre 1941 trois
pétroliers qui se trouvait dans le port
de gibraltar n'avait sombre et même
processus
une énorme explosion à l'incendié le
bateau qui coule on se perd comme on dit
en conjectures car enfin comment est ce
qu'on a pu faire couler ces bateaux le
port est à l'abri des sous-marins ya un
énorme filet aux mailles d'acier
et pourtant alors on envoie les
scaphandriers une planche et il découvre
qu'on la pratiquait dans le filet des
troncs on les a cisaillé et probablement
même à la cisaille et l'air comprimé et
on comprend on comprend que c'est le
fait que cette attaque que cette
explosion a été le fait des hommes
grenouilles ou des hommes torpille comme
on voudra italien il faut dire que le
corps des hommes grenouilles italiens
les hommes torpille sous la direction
notamment du prince valerio borghese
s'est littéralement couvert de gloire
pendant
guerre mondiale il était très en avance
il avait un équipement qui correspond
pratiquement à celui qui te connaissons
nos jours et il n'avait pas l'équivalent
dans le camp allié et c'est le petit
lionel crabe dans son bureau qui a eu
l'idée de former pour faire la parade un
corps d'homme grenouille britannique
évidemment ça n'avait rien à voir au
départ crabe a raconté lui même que les
premiers camarades qui l'a recruté avait
un équipement très élémentaire il avait
simplement un maillot de bain des
chaussures de tennis auquel on l'avait
attachée des semelles de plomb en pis
deux bonbonnes de deux bouteilles
d'oxygène avec dés semblent attachés aux
épaules et bien malgré tout malgré cet
équipement extrêmement élémentaire ils
allaient vivre des prodiges entre autres
exploits de lionel crabes
un jour il rencontre sous la mer
évidemment car maintenant il va vivre
presque toujours sous la main il
il rencontre un homme grenouille italien
et alors là c'est le combat c'est le
combat au couteau
on imagine ce que ça doit représenter et
enfin un moment lionel grab arrive à
fendre la combinaison de caoutchouc de
l'italien il voit les bulles d'air qui
s'élève et évidemment c'est la mort de
l'italien une autre fois lionel crav a
cherché sous un navire une mine qu'il
découvre une mine qui était déposée par
les italiens et il arrive à retirer il
entend le tic-tac pendant qu'il enlève
cette mine et on imagine évidemment
l'angoissent de cet homme il arrive à
enlever la mine l'emmène en nageant le
plus vite possible très loin du bateau
arrive à désamorcer la mine et quand il
a fini la forteresse experts qui diront
eh bien vous savez qu'il vous restait 23
secondes à la fin de la guerre
lionel crabe organise plein corps
d'homme grenouille italien qui sera
chargé de déminer les ports et là il se
rend compte qu'il est déjà célèbre en
italie on l'accueille comme un ami on
l'accueille comme une vedette et il est
célèbre non seulement l'italie mais
aussi dans un pays on parlera beaucoup
lionel grave après la guerre on lui
consacrera énormément d'articles même
des livres et évidemment il est
démobilisé il crée une petite fabrique
de meubles avec un ami
et malgré tout la plongée sous marine
continue être pour lui son sport favori
pour le compte de l'amirauté il continue
un certain nombre de missions lui
demande d' explorer des épaves et alors
chaque fois il s'en va passer quelques
jours dans la mer et il touche
d'ailleurs une cinquantaine de livres
sterling en 1953 c'est plus important en
1953 un croiseur russe un croiseur
soviétique arrive dans un port
britannique aspect turned c'est le ver
nov
et là on est très étonné en angleterre
car le commandant eastburn of a refusé
les services du pilote et le service de
tous remorqueurs et on voit cette énorme
croise entrer dans le port avec une
facilité déconcertante extraordinaire
jamais on a vu ça le bateau manoeuvre
comme si c'était une petite barque de m
et on voit que le commandant soviétique
a dans son poste de pilotage
un mystérieux clavier il appuie sur des
boutons et c'est en l'appuyant sur ce
clavier qu'il manoeuvre c'est énorme
immédiatement les marins britanniques
les experts se pose des questions
est ce que il n'ya pas des procédés
nouveaux est ce que là où dispose pas
par exemple une coque révolutionnaires
ou de plusieurs gouvernail et on demande
à crabes de plonger pour aller voir sous
ce fameux bâton il semble que la mission
n'est pas été entièrement couronnée de
succès puisque en 1956 quand laure
johnny kidd ce qui est l'homologue du
smirnov arrive à portsmouth on redemande
à lionel crabe d'aller voir de plus près
ces fameux procédé révolutionnaire des
bateaux soviétique alors le 19 avril
nous revenons point de départ le 19
avril 7 heures du matin avec ce
mystérieux smith crabe quitte le salé
porte hôtels et on n'entend plus parler
de lui évidemment les amis de crabes
s'inquiètent les jours passent rien
cette inquiétude transparaît dans la
presse on se demande ce qu'est devenu
crabes les a mis en alerte les
journalistes
cap d'ailleurs été mariée mais il était
séparé de sa femme margaret depuis un
certain temps et alors c'est le
communiqué de l'amirauté l'amirauté
britannique qui déclare que le
commandeur lionel crabe est présumé
avoir trouvé la mort au cours d'une
plongée effectué par les rien d'autre
rien d'autre pendant des mois
et puis un jour un pêcheur aperçoit
cadavres qui flottent entre deux où ils
l'attrapent avec une gaffe et c'est un
bien curieux viana car le canard n'a pas
de tête et n'a pas le bras il est
pourtant revêtu d'une combinaison
dangereuse
alors évidemment le cadavre
m autopsiées et subir des examens
médicaux et en même temps on va
soumettre la combinaison est en même
temps le tricot de corps bleu marine en
laine bleu marine qui est sous la
combinaison aux fabricants des
combinaisons dont se servait cramer le
fabricant est formel c'est une
combinaison dit il que j'ai fabriqué et
que j'ai livré aux commentaires crabe et
en plus le tricot de corps bleu marine
et bien c'est bien ce qu'ils mettaient
en général sous sa combinaison
alors c'est un témoignage important on
convoque malgré tout madame margaret
crabes
elle épouse séparée de g et elle ne
reconnaît pas le corps pourtant elle a
vécu des années avec ramé évidemment il
n'y a pas de tête qui a pas de maman
enfin elle connaît le reste du corps de
son ancien mari elle leur collègue
malgré tout il y a donc un acte un acte
légal on se fie à l'autopsié qui ne
prouvent rien portant on se fit surtout
au témoignage du fabricant de
combinaisons et on déclare mort
le commandant leonel grave on est clair
qu'on a découvert son cadavre
est-ce que l'affairé réglée absolument
deux ans plus tard nous sommes en 1959
un dossier arrive en angleterre il l'a
été acheminés par les services secrets
il vient de au delà du rideau de fer et
c'est un journaliste
berne a retenu qui va publier les
éléments de ce dossier ces dossiers
affirme que crabe lorsqu'elle était allé
espionner car en face c'est le mot sous
la coque de l'ordre liquide avait été
capturé par les soviétiques des hommes
grenouilles soviétique avait plongé
l'avait trouvée ils avaient capturé il
avait été emmené très loin il avait été
emmené au delà des eaux territoriales là
un hélicoptère l'avait conduit à steene
on l'avait interrogé pendant des jours
pendant les semaines
alors vous avez voulu espionner non vous
avez espionner non vous savez vous
risquez le peloton d'exécution je n'ai
pas espionné cela va durer une durée
durée on l'avait interrogé à moscou des
professionnels et un jour devant le
marché très précis où le peloton
d'exécution ou en revanche si vous
l'avouer pas pour éviter le peloton
d'exécution ou vous engagé dans la
marine soviétique et vous diriger
désormais les travaux de ces équipes de
vaugrenier et affirmer ce dossier
crabe pour sauver sa vie avait accepté
ce marché alors évidemment on s'était
servi de sa combinaison de son tricot de
corps dont on avait revêti un cadavre à
cadavres évidemment dont on avait enlevé
la tête et les bras
attention aux empreintes digitales et on
lave est immergée ce cas là voilà ce
qu'affirme et ce dossier est ce que
c'est aussi était vrai est ce que ce
dossier était sérieux il y avait une
photo dans ce dossier une photo qui
représentait d officier soviétique et
monsieur une tonne était allé montrer
cette photo à madame margaret grave et
parmi les officiers de marine soviétique
margaret crabe a formellement reconnu
son mari qu'il faut il croire l'amirauté
britannique a continué à affirmer que
tout cela n'était pas sérieux que la
photo était trop floue pour qu'on
reconnaisse quelqu'un d'une manière
certaine et pourtant margaret frappe dit
c'est mon mari quelques temps plus tard
ou plutôt quelques années plus tard car
ceux ci se situe il y a deux ans
seulement
on l'a découvert un crâne on a découvert
un crâne près du lieu où crabe auraient
disparu
le sommet d'un crâne seulement la
mâchoire supérieure
on a pu rien en déduit alors est ce que
quelque part au delà du rideau de fer
comme l'affirmait encore l'année
dernière le journal allemand bild en
allemagne de l'est maintenant comme le
dit bild se trouverait crabe à la tête
des hommes grenouilles de l'allemagne de
l'est ou bien réellement at il périt par
une avarie matérielle ou un accident
alors qu'il allait chercher les secrets
de leur gueule et guide est ce
réellement son cadavre qu'on a découvert
est peut-être son crâne qu'on l'a
découvert il ya deux ans on le saura je
crois peut-être un jour
[Musique]